In the world of TV police procedurals, Longmire
stands alone. The series follows a small police
department in the middle of Wyoming, where
dirt roads replace city concrete and the law
officers wear cowboy boots. Needless to say,
the story of Longmire is far from ordinary.
Longmire is set in the fictional Absaroka
County, Wyoming. The series, however,
is mostly filmed in New Mexico.
Specifically it's shot in Santa Fe,
Pecos, Los Alamos, and Las Vegas, New Mexico -
not to be confused with the Nevada casino town.
The Valles Caldera around Las
Vegas stands in for many of the
breathtaking Wyoming exteriors,
including Walt Longmire's cabin.
The Las Vegas plaza stands in for the
town and workplace of Longmire and the
interiors are also shot in New Mexico, at
a place called Garson Studios in Santa Fe.
New Mexico offers a 25-35 percent tax credit,
whereas Wyoming tops out at 15 percent so it's
no surprise that Longmire shoots down south.
New Mexico also has easier transportation and
more airports. The busiest airport in the
whole state of Wyoming is Jackson Hole,
with only one terminal and nine gates.
Plus its roads run across mountains,
rivers and canyons where extreme winter weather
has been known to cause closures as late as June.
Any production shot in wild places will
face challenges. When filming out west,
one of those challenges can be wildfires.
While filming Season 2 in 2013, wildfires
surrounded the set locations. The Thompson
Ridge Fire raged on one side of the preserve,
while the Tres Lagunas Fire hemmed them in from
another direction, covering the sky with smoke.
At first producers tried to shift locations.
Given the fact that the small area in New Mexico
was full of firefighters and emergency crews,
however, producer Chris Donahue said to
the Albuquerque Journal that they halted
everything because they, quote, "didn't want
to be in the way of any of the responders."
The Arizona-based Granite Mountain
Hotshots were part of the team
that eventually put out the fires.
Unfortunately, on June 30th, 2013,
19 of those firefighters died fighting
the Yarnell Hill Fire near Prescott.
The season 2 finale, "Bad Medicine," honored
the deceased hotshots in the credits by saying,
"Dedicated to the Granite Mountain
Hotshots and all the firefighters who
saved the historic buildings in the
Valles Caldera National Preserve."
Those heroic firefighters would
end up inspiring their own movie,
Only the Brave, starring Josh Brolin,
Miles Teller, and Jeff Bridges.
Longmire opened up with strong numbers and its
ratings grew over the first three seasons. Season
2 rose to about 6 million viewers and season 3
only dropped slightly to 5.6 million viewers.
And yet despite the high ratings, Longmire
got canceled after just three seasons.
"Why?"
It was unexpected considering the fact that season
3 ends in a cliffhanger with a father possibly
killing his son. But, there was another reason for
the cancellation: Longmire's fans were too old.
A&E said it canceled the hit show
because the average viewer age was 60,
versus the 48-year-olds who made
up A&E's average demographic.
So apparently it took A&E 3 seasons to
figure out that a police procedural about a
cantankerous old cowboy sheriff who refuses to
get a cellphone might appeal to older viewers.
After Longmire was canceled, Warner
Horizon, the producer of Longmire,
began shopping it around. Given the large audience
there was obviously demand, especially due to the
season 3 cliffhanger. A&E had said that the older
audience was less appealing to advertisers, but
Netflix doesn't have to worry about advertisers.
So, it was a perfect match for the series.
Netflix picked up the first three seasons and
announced it would launch new ones. Eventually,
Netflix canceled the series too, though
the streamer's reasons are still unknown.
At least it gave the team behind
Longmire the ability to finish
their series with a proper finale in season 6.
Jacob Nighthorse is a calculating, slippery and
calm villain throughout the Longmire TV series.
Even his rise in the tribal committee can be
traced to a murder early on in the series. Yet,
Nighthorse doesn't appear in
any of the Longmire books.
Nighthorse is the most unpredictable
and dynamic character in the TV series.
A businessman and casino owner, he's often an
enemy of the Absaroka Sheriff's department,
and at times even an enemy of his own tribal
law enforcement. But then, he'll testify on
Walt's behalf or support Cady Longmire's
effort to become a lawyer for the tribe.
The performance in the series by actor A
Martinez is so compelling that his name
ended up inspiring a character in the Longmire
novel Depth of Winter, Dr. Adan Martinez.
While the character is a great show of
appreciation to Nighthorse and A Martinez,
this new doctor can't compare to Nighthorse
for impact on the series and Longmire's life.
There have been many changes from
the books to the television series,
but this one adds texture to
the mythology of Walt Longmire.
Absaroka County doesn't exist in Wyoming.
Craig Johnson, the novelist who created
Absaroka County in his Longmire book series,
settled down in Ucross, Wyoming, after years of
traveling around the country. However, Johnson
has said that the basis for the town of Durant
is Buffalo, Wyoming, and Buffalo is the
seat of Johnson County. So it would seem
Absaroka County is based on the real Johnson
County. But would Walt Longmire stop there?
No. He'd look at the fact that the Wyoming
counties named after mountain ranges,
such as Teton and Uinta, have part or all of
that range in it. The Absaroka Mountains run
just east of Yellowstone and the Tetons
and extend down to the Wind River Range.
In the episode called "Population
25," Vic Moretti's husband,
Sean, says they're five hours from Jackson
Hole. The combination of the distance from
Jackson as well as the location of the
range leads to Durant being near Cody,
Wyoming, or possibly Thermopolis,
the seat of Hot Springs County.
On a map seen in the sheriff's office, however,
the location for Durant is right
where the real-world Sheridan is.
Where is this Absaroka then? That's a
mystery fit for Walt Longmire himself.
Buffalo, Wyoming, gets the credit for being
the real-life Durant because Johnson said
the town's layout and buildings served as
inspiration while writing the books. And
it makes sense given that the town only had
a county sheriff and his team of deputies.
So, there's a Longmire festival
in Buffalo, Wyoming. Longmire Days
features events inspired by the book and TV series
as well as interactions with the cast and crew.
Some of the highlights include talks
with Robert Taylor and Craig Johnson,
a horseback ride with some of the
actors, a softball game, and an auction.
There's even a chance to grab a drink at
the Red Pony and in the past they've had
events like a talk from the "Two Henrys" in the
show. That event happened during a Longmire Days
festival when the organizers held a talk with Lou
Diamond Phillips, who plays Henry in the series.
"It is a beautiful day at the Red Pony
and continual soiree. This is Henry. "
Robert Taylor, who plays Sheriff Walt Longmire, is
another Australian actor who excels at playing an
American tough. Show co-creator John Coveny
said in an interview with AssignmentX that,
"[Their] character combination for Walt was
Harrison Ford, Clint Eastwood, and Steve McQueen."
Coveny went on to explain that they
found that all in Robert Taylor.
For his part, Taylor said to Front
Row Features the role needed a quote,
"quietness of soulfulness" that
isn't often seen anymore. He added,
"You would see it in actors like
Gary Cooper and Clint Eastwood,
but I didn't base my character
on any of those guys."
While Robert Taylor may not have purposely
channeled personality traits from all those
legendary cinematic actors, they seem to fit
him like a pair of well-broken-in cowboy boots.
Robert Taylor has been kicking around
Hollywood for years but his most popular and
longest-running role is playing Sheriff Walt
Longmire. However, the role of Walt Longmire
almost went to Coach Taylor, or more specifically
the actor who played him, Kyle Chandler.
Chandler's turn as the coach on the NBC
show Friday Night Lights brought him a
lot of industry buzz. He went on to other
roles in many acclaimed movies, such as Argo,
Zero Dark Thirty, The Wolf of Wall
Street, and Manchester by the Sea.
While Chandler's early career included
a country movie, the actor himself is a
bit of a joker and might've brought some
of the levity to the series that Longmire
carries through the book series. As he's
matured, Chandler has also adopted a bit
of the roguish tough cowboy look that
would've fit the sheriff we all know.
Executive producer Hunt Baldwin grew up in
Chicago and worked in advertising for many years.
His parents moved to Wyoming and that bold
move inspired him to eventually leave his
safe existence and move to Los Angeles
to become a full-time writer. There he
worked hard for many years before
eventually fulfilling his dream,
working with his writing partner John
Coveny on their series, The Closer.
Baldwin and Coveny are both represented
by the same agent at talent agency CAA,
and it was that shared connection
at CAA that gave rise to Longmire.
According to Coveny, they had talked to their
agent over the years about wanting to do a
modern western. Coveny mentioned that he had been
a big fan of Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid.
Their agent then mentioned that CAA
also happened to be representing an
author named Craig Johnson who'd written a
series of modern day westerns centering on a
cowboy sheriff. According to Coveny,
they read The Cold Dish and said,
"About ten pages in we knew it was
something we wanted to develop."
Baldwin and Coveny's experience working
together on LAPD police procedural The
Closer was a big help when they began developing
Longmire. They still needed an executive producer
with experience running a show, though. Luckily,
while at The Closer, they met and worked closely
with producer Greer Shephard. So they set up a
meeting with her to discuss this new project.
Greer is a TV veteran. She produced her first
series in 1997, Nothing Sacred. One of her
first big hits as an executive producer
was Nip/Tuck in 2003. She was the perfect
person to shepherd two first-time creators
through a decidedly unique police procedural.
According to Baldwin and Coveny's interview with
AssignmentX, it took about three years from that
first sit-down to Longmire eventually premiering
on A&E. It quickly became a relationship made in
TV heaven. In fact, Shephard mentioned in a 2012
interview with The Hollywood Reporter that if she
could add any writer to her staff, she would,
quote, "clone Hunt Baldwin and John Coveny."
There are many differences between
Craig Johnson's Longmire books and
Baldwin and Shephard's Longmire TV series. And
while the book plots inspire the storylines,
the series has created many new stories.
In the books, Absaroka County
only had five murders in 24 years,
yet police procedurals on TV tend to
have lots of murders because it makes
for very compelling television. In Longmire,
there's a new murder almost every episode.
Also in the books, Walt Longmire's wife
isn't murdered, but instead dies of cancer.
His wife's murder in the TV series is a central
plot point in the series. But one of the
largest differences is Longmire himself.
In the books, Walt Longmire is witty. Many would
say he's wryly humorous. In fact, the books are
often praised for their humor. But Robert Taylor
plays Sheriff Walt Longmire straight, almost
to a fault. The only comedy we see from TV Walt
Longmire is when he makes social or technological
faux pas, a humor generated from everybody else's
reactions to his unwillingness to embrace the
modern world. In the few moments when Walt says
something funny, he doesn't seem to realize it.
There are many peculiarities that make Longmire
and its protagonist so memorable. The fact Walt
doesn't have a cellphone, nor does
he ever use gloves at crime scenes,
are just two. But one of the most well-noted
ticks is Walt Longmire's devotion to Rainier beer.
Rainier is a cheap beer that isn't found
all over, comparable in price to PBR,
and also owned by Pabst Brewing Company. In
an interview with the Casper Star Tribune,
Johnson explains he was surprised by how
Longmire has impacted Rainier beer. Johnson said,
"I figured Walt's not a
blueberry, microbrew kind of guy."
Johnson also charges one very
inexpensive and unique item
for speaking at any and all Wyoming
libraries — a six-pack of Rainier.
There's one more connection, though. The Longmire
Historic District in Washington is the location
of Mount Rainier National Park. So perhaps that
Longmire-Rainier connection may have influenced
Johnson in naming his famous sheriff. There are no
confirmed statements that say Walt's last name was
inspired by his favorite beer. So this might just
be another mystery for Walt Longmire. But, when it
comes to tying together supposed coincidences
to suss out the truth, there's nobody better.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.